oh that okay so it says we're a lot guys
welcome everybody to episode 7 of red
cafe and in this episode we're going to
discussing animes sequels let me just
figure out why I'm hearing a background
noise guys you guys see how uri dul it's
a little echoey yeah yeah I can echo I
am too are you guys in the same room you
and oh yeah that might be up that is
definitely gonna be it but it's got this
little Cathedral reverb going on so it's
kind of gonna go yeah I'm a fan of
reverb reverb guys alright so goes and
don't talk if we leave the room yeah
what you get into the chassis I guys
feel free to talk until we figure our
technical stuff up they'll pay to uh get
into it I introduce yourselves we can
start with friend then go to a salon
blizzard and hold a anime bread uh say
again welcome hello hi yes my channel no
son I'm friend nice to see you well I
have an ad my channel Prince fandom what
links are all down below low I'm trying
to get up everything to so sorry i
missed a statement but i know i was just
saying words well there I was trying to
find chat too so I could visit with
people on chat so if there's anyone here
we can say hello there are some people
here at your shadows going crazy Oh chat
is going crazy i see regulars Jonathan
Essex Kaiser trigger you know clear as
well as well feedback very nice it's
great to see you uh Sinai blizzard i do
first impressions occasionally uh they
may make you laugh or cry for various
reasons so I'm glad to be a part of
cafe again hopefully I will try not to
bore everyone with random stuff like it
last time so but it's pleasure to be
part of it also by the way go watch
Brynn fandoms speed painting video it is
fantastic i have to plug that because
that's a really good video I haven't you
know yet I really need to check that out
is the fully trained guys check out
bring and of course on a blizzard an old
anime but old anime tell us about
yourself bro I am Briggs from all the
anime I i make FAQ video of the things
about Adam a pretty cool god I can
confirm this they're true it is they're
cool oh yeah okay I like I ended up
going into that genre just because I
really like watching the videos yeah can
you guys hear me now with echo is it
better khmer double oh no it's okay work
it out check it out do you see the guy
right behind me that's goes in right
there what's up soon trip this is pretty
cool it looks so what oh so Briggs you
you introduce your summer reading yes
yeah okay cool welcome guys and let me
just explain what's going on here
basically our friends that we grew up
with they have their creative designers
basically they do like art design all
this kind of stuff digital design both
and they have their own like physical
space now like a physical office but
it's not really an office like it's like
a lounge like a creative space where
they just do cool stuff they do they're
designing people coming in just hang out
it's like very like new age but there
you only doing the nagger region doing
it and actually invited us to do the
live stream from here just kind of like
with a bunch of other people just doing
creative stuff so we said we'd love to
do it and now we're here what's up man
someone's saying hello but there's also
big windows right in front of us like
it's like it's like on a street on a
Main Street I'd like people just walking
by their life looking like what are
these people doing so they're like
looking at my face as we're doing this
pretty cool it's pretty cool but yeah so
looking forward to this discussion
because I was just talking with Michael
cyanide blizzard the other day and he we
were talking with all the sequels that
are coming out of this this coming year
and our first thought was yes we're
going to be no
not for views on YouTube but our second
thought was is is this going to be a
great thing for anime in general for the
anime industry because uh Michael you
mentioned the whole how did you call it
sequel itís ya xuan Hollywood movies
where it's like yeah where we have just
like a whole bunch of sequels being made
because that's what sells and then that
threatens to kind of um threatens
original new creative words that might
not get produced because we have such in
flux or just like sequels like let's
just make code geass season 3 let's just
make you know law tak on Titan season 2
blue exorcist all these different anime
coming back one punch man right so is
there a my first question is is there a
danger that we're going to see a kind of
original anime creative anime kind of
going down the drain because of this
whole sequel issue because of course we
know sequel cells they already have the
buzz so then why not just make a bunch
of sequels why not make cowboy bebop
season four and five what do you guys
think I'll start with you Michael since
we started this convo the other day on
Twitter it's it's really interesting
because yeah I'd mentioned that we're
really seeing explosion of sequels
Dragon Ball super Sailor Moon crystal
and then we're going to be seen a new
season of copious as well as a return to
Cardcaptor Sakura which is it's really
interesting because all four of those
shows I guess in their own right were
really big shows obviously for Sailor
Moon and Dragon Ball being far bigger
but nonetheless you know they were still
quite popular and it just it does really
pose an interesting question you know is
this getting to a point where companies
are being reliant upon sequels or
anniversary dates to bring back shows as
opposed to exploring newer shows on one
of the big things we think of with that
there was an incident way back in 2011
where um it's kind of interesting
because I believe you caught Yamamoto
had this really strong desire to just
focus you know we need to bring back
original animation and he worked on
fractal fractal bomb it did not do well
and
since then it sort of been you know kind
of a hey is that how things are going to
the future ken original anime just
simply not survive in this current
market and I think for right now things
are balanced enough enough time has sort
of passed but I'm worried about
potentially entering the same region
that the Western market did for a lot of
movies especially horror movies where we
saw a revival of things like Halloween a
Friday the 13th I think adjacent as well
I'd have to look back in again I'm
probably setting some things that
haven't been yet but it's just I guess
comes to a point of what's too far what
is it in what potentially is taking away
I guess the attention or possibility of
attention from newer series and
furthermore how well these new shows
will do um Dragon Ball super and Sailor
Moon crystal upon first impressions and
inception did not do well they were very
negatively received I think it's sort of
balanced out now I haven't checked out
the actual sales statistics to really
gauge that but I know in terms of
reaction they were not received very
strongly so that sort of begs the
question with code geass coming up and
then later on next year with Cal captor
sakura you know how will those do and I
guess I'm mixed because i like seeing
original animation but obviously we're
in a time where it's a business you have
to make money and it's harder for
studios than ever and more expensive for
them to produce anime and if it's not
making any money which in the case of
fractal has mentioned before a one
didn't really produce a profit from that
and we've seen them go a different
direction as a result since then so I'd
be curious to know what a Bryn and all
the anime think about that you're not
curious about goes in the video ok I'm
just gonna ignore me I was told to
ignore him you know he doesn't let us
fair he's right he's right there would
like your opinion as well actually but
yeah I'm thanks um Michael that was very
good point in exactly after they know if
the industry knows that sequels sell why
not just make a whole bunch of sequels
then risk something new and but that of
course is big danger because sometimes
sequels become
very bad because they don't know what
they're doing they're just trying to
kind of milk in and that's been the fear
with if somehow expressed with code
geass for example and also that means
that a lot of new ideas that might have
been successful will be kind of stomped
out at the start because they're like
well we don't have a proven market for
this so we're not gonna make them I just
want to give a shout out to a few people
in the child we got bean Boing and creep
Ellen in there which King my Serbian
buddy what's up bro um yeah it's
Orthodox Christmas Eve tomorrow I know
can't wait reservoir warrior what's up
bro I'm some table goals and are getting
calls everyone's who's he talking to
okay production are you guys talking
about original anime as in like there's
no prior adaptation whatsoever in terms
of manga and mike novels correct because
like I think that's always been a
problem like no it's all we did a
problem for that they always try to base
it off mango or light novels so they
already have no fan base and bring some
amount of fans I guess now what we're
seeing is sequel but now you already
have a dedicated fan base in terms of
the anime adaptation as well kind of
like a double the kind of typical me I'm
happy in the sense that I feel like in
the past we never used to get sequels
asked for at all and i only have to go
and read the manga or light novel so I'm
kind of happy that a lot of shows like
one punch man and my bracket email which
I was really I'm like I really enjoyed
are actually getting new seasons this
year but I'd also all cheap under too
much in like is this a good kind of
animal is it going to become like all
sequels and all like long-running shows
and no longer a new works I'm take a
look at point yeah Brynn what do you
think no I agree with what everyone's
pretty much saying that like it's nice
getting second seasons it's nice knowing
that an anime that you've invested in
watching is going to have more and for
the most part I I don't mind
long-running series as long as I haven't
started it and it has started it was too
much metal back at me and it's just so
much a personal worth it but like I've
been chatting with people and like I
want to watch gintama Thomas
a lot of episodes like do I invest my
time people are like yeah you totally
should but the same is like hunter
hunter like fairy tale now I know like a
million francs where you have so many
episodes that it's good it's nice
because there's a fan base for that but
I mean I just haven't watched target all
of those shows so it's hard to go back
and Finch wash it but I would prefer to
see more original content like to
reflect not manga itself as well but
even manga adaptation so you know light
not left adaptations into anime is also
great but um if I've watched it with it
when it has started it's worth my time
but if not it's too much to go back and
it's hard to say like oh I should go
back and I guess watch the first season
cuz there's a second and third season
coming out that's my only bad so cuz
that potentially lead to like it being
hard for new anime Watchers to get into
anime if it's like the majority of each
anime season are sequels then people
would be like re i'm not going to go
back and watch either one so it's less
to choose from the bringing new viewers
i don't know i guess i could be a way to
look at it no i think so depend upon
episode length you know Bryn you made a
really good point there length really
drives a lot of people away yeah yeah
yeahs for me feel like them yeah even
something like we're talking about our
favorite anime that we'd like to bring
out code geass but like for someone to
be like oh go and watch it but you're
like oh that's a lot of episodes like do
I actually go back and invest the time
and everyone who's watches like yes you
should but yet like there's just so much
episodes and knowing that there's gonna
be more it's like do I really want to
invest all that time and energy for new
anime Watchers it might push people away
yeah well that's a good point but it's
also for a quote yes it's only like 50
episodes like what the real crazy ones
are you know the bleach and naruto and
you know one piece like briggs would all
love us to watch one piece of course but
the problem is yeah like there's no way
we can start one piece and it's like
what eight hundred episodes like how
many so like that's like yeah like even
up to 100 episode I feel like episodes
if you like is ok but then after that
it's like yeah it's like just crazy
territory so and it's
very hard to like start but then
everyone's talking about it they're cool
did you read the latest chapter one
piece of chapter eight hundred
fifty-eight thousand like a fashion that
was the best one in the last round a
thousand for sure play um I forgot the
opposite of opposite opinion looking
like she a series had like fifty to a
hundred episodes and i both started
watching and i'm like so happy i okay
actually i was using amount of content
to enjoy it well I look at a series that
I here is good and I only has 12
episodes I know that even be some future
disappointment when I'm done I'm gonna
finish in like a day and then I thought
that there is yeah kind of if you
binge-watch that's true it's true it's
not like you don't want to finish it
it's like we with me with kaijo like I
just I don't want it to be over gonna
that's actually a really good point to
look at because especially I'm glad Bryn
mention that because especially in
today's market were you know were sort
of a ADHD type culture where you know we
want things immediately tldr you know we
want short sweet and to the point to
where even an eMac you proper great
point you know 50 episodes isn't that
many episodes but for someone new they
may be like oh man 50 episodes I don't
want to watch that but yet I Briggs that
was a else a really great point see
that's why I used to love I look at a
show if there was already a lot of
seasons that I'd be like oh man I can't
wait to you know just enjoy this
throughout the entirety so I think it
kind of depends almost on mentality when
you're approaching the show as well but
I fee like that's because we're like
really dedicated anime fans if like
someone new into anime like I know I try
to get people in damn it I always try to
choose like 12 episode shows so it's
like or like 24 episode shows guy know
if they see 50 to 100 like there's no
way I could get someone who doesn't
watch anime into one piece that would
never happen in a million years both
like I guess what I'm trying to say is
simply depends on like how many will
animate walk and all to your mentality
like you said like some people prefer
seasonal anime well like I don't but
it's fascinating to because the Western
market mostly grew on shows like Dragon
Ball sailor moon Io Naruto Bleach one
piece like those are really what drew a
lot of people into the anime community
so you know that's this the thing it's
like a lot of episodes
people way but yet at the same time
those type of shows will bring people
into the community yeah I guess I like
that kind of counters my points like I
was saying that I guess like how having
only sequels people want to want to go
back and watch season one but the same
time a lot of these anime are really
hype like one punch man my hero academia
attack on titan they had like they
garnered a lot of hype so now they're
gonna like I guess they're actually
considered gateway added me at this
point the kind of count as I point might
actually bring in more people no I still
think it's something really to consider
and it's true because whenever I've
recommended show is that's the thing I
think of immediately is okay you know
it's usually like okay how how is this
on a scale of weirdness for introducing
people it's like oh that's anime no it's
how friendly is it to people who aren't
familiar with that and also you know
more importantly the episode count cuz
you know so i think that's no that's a
really good thing to consider cuz you
know it's just that's just it with
gateway shows like that being shorter
such as attack on titan my hero academia
and such as longer shows but yet also
been more popular ones you know what
determines that factor yeah and Gustav
actually mentioned it in the chat that
he is having a tough time selling a
hunter hunter to his friend because of
the lot of episodes and yeah I i started
i started hunter hunter too but then i
ended up stopping after that first kind
of 25 episode arc because i wasn't that
motivated to continue even though people
say oh that's you know that's the worst
arc you should keep going or something
it gets better and better but again it's
like you're thinking okay well then i
have to watch a hundred more episodes I
wasn't done it sold on in the first 25
so yeah it's definitely an issue and
yeah good points aren't I in Hunter
hunter I like the beginning stages but
it is one anime that I could say like it
doesn't have like you didn't start going
downhill I just keep trying like rising
like I said like the peak just keeps on
getting bigger I think you're thinking
of gurren lagann yeah get in there
somehow log on it had a couple like I
think I started to get bored a little
dom's upset after communi a couple
episode by than ever
in my backup for my like my enjoyment
levels exactly it's funny because they
do that whole thing with Simone kind of
being a crybaby for a while yeah like a
Shinji but then instead of being Shinji
for the whole series or like that got
from eureka seven he actually a few
episodes later like kind of like gets
his [ __ ] together and then we get to see
a good show against oh yeah I feel like
it's a really cool show that's kind of
challenges tropes a lot so yeah for sure
by the way the most excited for their go
ahead sorry what were you saying other
thing what you guys most excited for but
you're the host so next question to you
no no that's good like I I I don't have
notes today so just feel free of far
away with your question yeah okay yes so
um I'm definitely most excited for kogi
us I think most people know that I've
made 18 million videos about it keep it
up and more are coming but yeah I'm
definitely excited for kogi us and for
attack on titan season 2 because i
watched multiple times we watch that
show and it ends on a cliffhanger and
i've been waiting since 2011 or whatever
it was for it to two drops and like in
the kept saying it's coming next year
right it's coming next year it's coming
it's like a it's like the new what's it
called kingdom hearts they've just been
like oh yeah it's coming don't worry
don't worry so I'm dumping stuff for
that and of course apparently one punch
man is coming to season as well right I
got this season season but this year
yeah apparently season 2 which yeah of
course if that's true I'm absolutely
excited for that to seven deadly sins
they were saying might be coming yeah
that's I'm fairly confirmed I'm pretty
hyped about that it's some more views
for me yeah exactly Briggs you make
seven deadly sins videos that are very
good and I enjoy so yeah what we got it
we got to do some colapse Briggs we're
just gonna hang some videos what about
the rest of you guys what are you most
excited for probably most excited for
Boca no hero cuz I really really enjoyed
it but also tack on Titan because like
you said like because must have been
2012 like 11 it's been a long time like
they could have done they had enough
content like years ago to continue on
but yet they did it I'm really excited
and the trailer actually really does
look good and so I'm like really
crossing my fingers that's going to be
just as great as Percy
but probably Boca new heroes still even
though there's a lot of good ones even a
little witch academia that one I watched
that one as well excited wash up this
season two yeah because blue witch
academia was just 20 VA's and we
actually just watched those two me and
goes and the other day and so we're
gonna probably on Sunday because Sundays
when the first episode is coming out
right like they're finally make into
serious we're gonna try to do a live
reaction thing on sunday we'll see how
that goes we've never done what I know
brain you've done a bunch of them so
help us I will send my help yeah we'll
try to figure that out so it watch it
watch out for that guys if you're on
Sunday if we if we can get it to work if
we can figure it out and find the subs
and all that kind of stuff I don't know
they're gonna do it on crunchyroll or
Netflix we do have both but we will see
if it's going to come out the same day
hopefully but that should be fun yes oh
yeah a little witch academia under form
ax I brought you that's like a really
cool show really like unique sure what
trigger likes to do trigger is just just
triggers us my right Kaiser Yellin I've
in the comments if noragami getting a
third season that would be awesome but
I'm not sure you guys know I don't think
so yeah I would hope so but I I don't
know so I shouldn't just say things true
I'm gonna look that up after and i'll
get back together I love it Michael what
are you excited for and make sure you
say something like I'm secure and I mean
no one's heard of oh well since since
nobody's mentioned the return of blue
exorcist I'll bring that up I I enjoyed
the first season of that I know if some
people didn't like it but it hit the
right notes for me so I appreciate that
yelling there's flames Khan al-assal you
know find so no it's it's really nice to
see really glad that attack on titan is
getting some attention I in wit as
literally hype the hell out of that that
was really smart them because yeah I
mean commentary came out and people are
like no we want to tack on Titan like
okay we'll give you that next year so
yeah now that's finally coming that's
nice to see a little witch academia it's
really nice to see I'm really curious
how triggers going to handle a TV
for that obviously uh my hero academia
needed more episodes we do not get
enough for that first season so no it's
it's really exciting um obviously I've I
own copious so I'm really curious to see
how they're gonna handle the third
season yeah for sure have you gotten to
finishing it yet oh yeah I've watched
all but I've I watched i binge-watched
it when i first got it so i may actually
need to rewatch it but i remember most
so okay okay good cuz i was gonna say
for those of you guys who are fans of
code geass we're probably going to do
both definitely want to do a live stream
on saturday at noon eastern standard
time talking about the latest news about
cone yes it's probably going to turn
that into a video about the latest news
what we know so far and all day I know
you're a fan of the show and cyanide if
you are as well then I would love to
have you on those streams if you're
available just let me know when you
check your schedule and brynn I know
you're not really into code yes but if
you were you would totally be invited
and that'd be down the column available
yeah yeah it should be fun and also I
wanna if you're new to the channel
welcome everybody who's good we've had
some pretty amazing growth lately with
the channel got a lot of new subscribers
something like 500 this week alone so if
you're new and you're watching thank you
for coming we're going to be having a
lot more content soon saturday is going
to be the CODIS live stream 12 p.m.
eastern time so 12 noon eastern time and
we're going to also be sending up a
special discord server for discussing
future videos and discussing all the
theories for Kody s and other anime
attack on titan all that kind of stuff
so definitely um we're going to give you
the link for the disc or server at the
live stream so be be there if you can
make it would love to have you and all
day you still haven't accepted my
invitation bro I a key just join that
before this dream Oh cuz I was gonna
believe that Brynn was there and sign up
alyssa was there and I was like where's
all day anime thank you that's gonna be
a fun fun time I told myself I was gonna
join it when I saw it cuz I like well
when I got home and I completely forgot
about it but then I like when I went to
check for the link for the google
hangout I saw the discourse think I'm
like
I'll join now good cuz hopefully we can
make your uh your stuff is gonna work
next time because yeah the first code
yes live stream we had was really well
it went really well we had a lot of
people watching me that I'm getting like
almost 3,000 views yeah well now with
another fun scream to watch stream yeah
except Briggs you were supposed to be a
guest but you know your stuff wasn't
working right so hopefully we can make a
working this done because yeah the more
people we have discussing these
interesting theories and kind of getting
the thoughts bouncing off each other the
better so absolutely sounds fun well
hopefully I have no idea what happened
with Ozzy just like internet issues
because like my actual tech stuff seem
to be working fine like Maya tested it I
would like another strip this internet
connecting to everyone um I don't did I
say what I was looking forward to you
said blue actions oh no no Michael so
much just wondering what did you see i
think is agreed with everyone okay um so
yeah obviously code years one hundred
percent my hero academia like that it's
a perfect enemy for me i'm specifically
hype for it because everyone's told me
that the first light the first arc or
the first thirty chaput which was the
what which one which was what the third
seal the first season was based off of
was like slowest or like the least hype
i guess so everyone's telling me like
the next season's gonna be amazing so
i'm looking forward to that I did yeah I
did like attack on Titan um I was really
hike with it but I kind of got bored
halfway through so a little bit less
hype for that one but at your opinion
what's attack by the way up for blue
extras i just started watching a blue
exorcist I'm five episodes in and so far
I really do like it so if I end up
enjoying it thoroughly I'm gonna
definitely be looking forward to the
second season um and someone but what
else did you just mention Briggs oh yeah
I can i yeah for a technic I deny feel
it did get a little bit slow it did get
a little bit slow like near the middle
like there was a lot of filler going on
and I don't know if that was because
they were catching up to the manga or
they were just trying to milk it but
there was a yeah like it was like the
one episode that I mention one like um
there's a smoke and they're all like
hiding from the smoke like in the smoke
from like the army that's surrounding
them and then like four three episodes
there just like chatting and the smoke
is like waiting for the small to
dissolve
and of course you know Armin and his
little freak outs that lasts for four
episodes in a row so yeah that I
definitely with you like but then I it
really picks up near the end and then
the twists and all that kind of stuff
and leaves you with a cliffhanger so
yeah I hope there's not that much filler
in the second season they definitely had
enough time and enough material now to
create a more interesting series but I
I'm looking forward to that hope is
going to be more fast-paced I hope we're
gonna get some freaking answers in the
anime two notches the manga just you're
going through the manga takk basement
what's in the basement right what is in
the basement already Josh didn't uh
didn't TIA Aaron carry like a rock for
like two episodes they gave him the
middle area oh I reliably like I mean
where they come making fun of that I
don't really remember it was there was a
lot of style members pizookie rock but
yeah was there was a lot just like
they're trying to weigh down there kind
of covered the entrance from what i
remember i dont rember be two episodes
but then i watched a video about it and
someone was making fun of that so i
guess that was the thing i just had a
really really like i don't really
complain about pacing too often but like
it had a really fast start and I really
hyped start like I was so into it and
it's like went down like a little bit
boring between yeah it was just about to
bring that up actually because yeah it
has a really crazy start like a crazy
beginning I goes in his reading the
manga right now actually is reading all
the whole manga and he's almost caught
up and he was saying like well like
reading the manga it just reminded me
how crazy the beginning was like how
crazy the beginnings and also does the
end of the second season was really
crazy a lot of twists a lot of
fast-paced things it's just that it
ended up being it some of those middle
parts ended up being kind of like oh man
get to it already like I didn't stop
watching it but it was it was there was
some you know it was another binge-watch
of all I guess you could say I find a
little bit more hard for me because I
was actually watching yet like as it was
airing it was like 10 like but what you
guys say that came out in it's been like
two thousand eleven or twelve or
something yeah like i like i was even
watching seasonal anime at that point in
time and like I was watching that like a
week by week
but I think that fast paced beginning is
what got a lot of people into it like
that was a good gateway because it was
like pack action crazy like the Titans
were freaky and weird that's what got me
hooked well partially hook to anime but
it helped was it was attack on Titan
because and it's also oh come back to
that Cole discussion we had like four
people who don't watch anime don't watch
a lot like seasons like this and anime
like this is a good gateway to get them
into that good stuff same with full
mouth was Brotherhood yes I see that I
didn't chat but yeah it's also a good
like really good gateway yeah I for me
actually was death note that not was the
first um adult anime kind of that I
watched that was like actually before I
thought you know as a kid of course I
grew up on Dragon Ball Z and your Naru
toes and things right but I I kind of
stopped watching her for a while and I
actually was goals and who got me my
brother got me back into it by showing
me stuff like death know where I was
like looking this is like well this is
not just like a kid's cartoon this is
really complex this is really
interesting so it was definitely I think
okeus was one of the like the second or
third anime I signed that also was like
so while my gateway enemy and I loved it
so yeah absolutely anything else go
ahead no I wasn't gonna say anything I
was just I was just like someone else
say something please oh I think I'll
started with like shorter series I'll
disappear shown in at the beginning like
my like back when I was a little bit
moral club that I am right now uh it was
pure dragon ball z here bleed Shannon
one piece and naruto i watch all those
early my first four or five yeah well I
think we all start like as I saw we had
here in the West or I like you you
didn't just wake up one day and say okay
I'm gonna go check out what kind of car
do is to make in Japan you were like
what's what's on TV right and do you see
that's like what I yeah it's a few new
friends who could connect you with
something else otherwise yeah basically
was whatever what was on TV and that was
what was on TV like that was the same
thing with me you know it's I remember
seeing Sailor Moon on TV and I was like
oh man those girls are cute so in
it was like yeah elementary school kid
they're like all older girls yes so but
no I mean that was just it is you know
you get introduced that and I think
that's fine I you know it's a lot of
shown in series get a bad rap and some
of its understandable i think they're
still plenty enjoyable to watch and they
certainly do serve a great place for
bringing people in the fandom i think
you know a lot of us can say that you
know we were introduced in some aspect
or another you know it's even with
attack on titan to a degree while that
doesn't necessarily fall under the same
parameters you know it's it's definitely
sort of got that same appeal to it yeah
for sure yeah any other sequels that we
haven't talked about yet that are coming
like really you're excited about her
worried about and i know i cannot sue
buys coming out right oh what a fool so
I think oh yes season 2 that is coming
out I is show a rack ago season two yes
a lot of people I you know wasn't a
terribly popular but a lot of people
really enjoyed it and it was it was done
really well it's very interesting hmm oh
so miles to show yeah yeah if sequels
become like the new thing um if they're
not already are we gonna like have
another cowboy diva are we gonna have
another full metal alchemist blood
Brotherhood they're slightly older now
what's happening what do you guys think
I mean I would like to see sequels to
like some the older anime that has been
out for a long time but it's kind of
well we I don't know if it'd be easier
or harder to resurrect those type of
animes cuz some like some of the older
older people who have watched the show
are like no it's classic don't touch it
the endings with ending you could argue
that's what like yes it's kind of like
or you have the opportunity for new
viewers to be like Oh what is this
cowboy bebop I should probably go watch
it because there's a second season or
like a fourth or whatever season coming
out someone would be harder easier to do
sequels I think older anime I'm a little
bit more okay with a Cody at Cody a
season three I don't think i would be
down for more cowboy bebop I'm just so
happy with how like not happy with how
it ended but I was very fulfilled like I
wouldn't I think they'd have like
yeah I'm sure you guys know the ending
we did have to make a cute ass ass bolt
even like bring back the series yeah
like on one hand we have this thing with
a lot of like good shows like the devil
is a part-timer getting just like you
know 12 13 episodes and then not getting
any anymore and like it's so
disappointing and then on the other hand
you're getting so many sequels season
for like older anime so it's like yeah
it's a two-edged sword I guess because
some of the sequels you want to see
you're excited for but some of the shows
you wanted to see more of like for me
the devil is a part-timer or like dead
men want to line things like that you
don't get to see enough of so yeah
that's also questions like are they just
like testing animate from now on just
here's collapse which you feeling really
well you're done we're going back to
making sequels one question I had for
you guys is what show what one show
would you think would be the hardest or
the craziest stupidest idea ever to make
a sequel to think like a bad idea our
boys something an anime that has a super
conclusive ending like everyone's dead
or something or like there's no possible
like a common good kill that's actually
a good one like how would you do a
second season of that like everybody's
not around so like um well if they
continue like from where the man you
left off they probably could ready then
they maybe could have been yeah they'd
have to take like a full metal alchemist
brotherhood approach where it's tries to
follow the mega more closely whereas
Fullmetal Alchemist deviated after a
point which is what happened with a
comedy got cable what about blue
exorcist like you guys yeah it's like
have you heard any information about
what it's like if you continuing the
story from the first evening the first
even like a laugh 10 15 episodes didn't
fall the manga at all yeah I'm in seen
haven't seen the wrist like I'm see only
the first five episodes i'm not sure but
yeah i haven't heard yet so cuz that
that's what i was curious about because
the way it was done I mean it's they
could have continued but yeah it was
like you said they deviated enough to
where it's like well okay what are you
gonna do and then they just stopped it
so it's like oh I guess you're not gonna
do anything but now they're bringing it
back so I don't know if they're gonna
you know what their plans for that are
it's gonna be really interesting so
what's your pick Michael for the worst
possible sequel to ever bring back ever
notice we have got killed for Brent that
that's tough to talk um I mean see
that's just it i think Brynn made a
really good point it's in that was sort
of a point that uh you know kind of a
queen Briggs's point as well there where
it's just if a show gives them really
satisfying or conclusive ending it's
kind of hard to wrap up you mentioned
deadman wonderland and devils a
part-timer i think those are really good
examples of kind of the directional
change in the industry where we switched
over to 12 episodes which is cheaper and
we get higher quality shows as a result
but we lose out on some of those
episodes and if they don't do well
enough we never see a second season so
specially especially the case of deadman
wonderland you know that needed a second
season so and goes unmentioned
highschool of the dead as well go Akashi
I mean well what happened to the manga
with that like the guy completely
dropped that for triage x i believe so
it's I mean yeah it's pretty much like
dead all around which is kind of a shame
because there's so much guilty pleasure
pneus in highschool the dead its
all-time nerd in everything looks like a
cage 02 is hilarious it's just hilarious
I love it well yeah bark briggs and rig
stop being such a coward and finish
watching cage or like a man oh do a live
up to that beard challenge accepted no
okay actually we're gonna do should do
like joint joint like reviews of um k
Joe like totally serious reviews just
like talking about like all the literary
merits symbolism embolism but they had a
lot of attacks that are like of like
copies of or like whatever like copies
of other animes I could get into
existing bosom of Gilgamesh is attack
the wick bites oh oh it's such a love
letter to shonen series like you know
just see that love
there's so many other series as well
it's absurd so Briggs what's your one
anime that you think would be a terrible
idea to bring back and we're gonna go
back to you Michael cuz I want you to
make a choice so this one technically is
game brought back but they're choosing
to do an alternate ending instead steins
gate I love steins gate I love the
ending of science eat the last like
three four episodes were amazing so it's
like I wouldn't want it to continue
really I'm like I'm satisfied with it
but they're doing an alternate ending I
can play through I guess where it
continues from episode 23 so I'm fine
with that as long as you don't continue
this eerie from where it left off I'm
good yeah I feel like it's unnecessary
though I don't feel like it adds
anything except maybe you know money for
for the creators but yeah Michael so
going back to you to you that you have
one it's like the worst idea ever trigun
you know it's there there's been like
there was tryin and tryin on maximum for
manga which I think was sort of a
continuation but it went a lot more of a
darker path but it's just um that was
sort of really my big gateway that was
the first series i bought I bought the
Hong Kong bootleg on ebay that that's
that's how I hardcore I got there into
that but that's sort of one of those
when they made the movie of it the movie
took place in between the series before
a very key event happened I don't want
to spoil anything in case no one's seen
it but that's one of those where it's it
sort of kind of concludes everything you
could continue the story but it's kind
of one of those where you go well you
don't really need to which gungrave was
a lot like that as well where you could
continue it but you don't really need to
because everything's really conclusive
as is so yeah good point good point I
actually liked trigona saw the movie and
the show and I really enjoyed it one
thing I was gonna say oh yeah so the
reason I asked you guys to do this is
now what I want you to do is put
yourself in a position of the writer who
has to write the sequel and tell me how
you would make it good oh-ho and we'll
start with You broom well well without
obviously getting spoilers to a konica
kill I would essentially have to add an
entire new cat
rest of characters just everybody would
have been knew it'd have to be a new
place a new setting I mean whoever's
around would be around but yeah you'd
have to just make up a whole bunch of
new characters which would be kind of
fun but yet it gets rid of the whole
like appeal for the season like
everything that you liked about it is
not there anymore because it's a whole
new anime so yeah so it's kind of like a
key to the exiled with code geass which
is an ova what's love drug which is an
ova for that they created basically they
took the world the same world you know
the countries that exist the powers but
then they moved it to europea or like
out of the other end of the world from
japan and had different characters and
then they had like a completely needless
cameo by Suzaku and luchshe that was
like why but the point is that yeah i
was like the child can take the world
and then create a whole new cast but for
in that case it definitely didn't work
they definitely didn't do it the way
they should have I didn't enjoy it
myself personally that there was a lot
of issues with a character development
and with the writing but yeah that's
definitely an option like if you have a
really cool world like I feel like the
world of death note could definitely be
rebooted my personal preference is to
have like some kind of like showdown
between the Shinigami and the Shinigami
world where why there's a death notice
dropped one on every continent and then
the goal is for them to like whoever the
one each person on each content against
the death note their goal is to
eliminate the other people with death
notes even though they don't know who
they are and to win kind of the value of
it so it's kind of like a fate the fate
series meets death note like I feel like
I would like to see something like that
for sure like obviously to carry the new
characters you create have to be
actually interesting but I think like
that world I think it's such a cool
concept that you definitely could a
future diary version but with that with
death notes yes hmm rendition I like the
idea that we call with so many like
mayonnaise anime we've got this now I'll
add half a new studio yeah we got the
new rank of a studio guys here at
moonbase
and in base I like before we end I can
take the camera a bit and move it around
and show you guys oh it is it's a very
cool creative space we call it a talent
hot spot right am I right guys yeah um
but yeah no it's fun it's fun fun times
in soul maka said something so much yeah
so like I said for death note if you
bring it back bring back L or I don't
want to see it haha that's what is so
tough because I mean that was the big
thing for so many people it was here his
battles with L were just it was so great
and I remember watching it when it was
coming out and that's all anyone could
talk about was just how great that was
and I don't want to spoil anything but
for the second half I mean you know
attention kind of petered afterwards and
understandably so because I mean where
do you go after that especially as a
writer you know it's there that was so
strong how do you how do you create
something that can go beyond that yeah
it was a really interesting choice by
the writers way because they didn't have
to kill L off the fact they decided to
do that was almost like I don't know if
they were like challenging themselves if
they're like okay so now we created this
awesome dynamic and instead of dragging
it out for a hundred episodes like some
anime have done right which they could
have that kind of milk that and then
people will be complaining oh well you
know that that went on for too long they
decides like no no we're gonna
completely cut ourselves off I'm gonna
kill off l and then see what happens
just see what happens and it looks like
yeah it was a really bold decision
because especially like I'm glad you
mentioned Melky because that's what a
lot of series will do in case is you
have that sort of good versus evil evil
battle you prolong that for as long as
possible but in death notes case they're
like okay no there's a clear decisive
goal this is what's going to happen and
especially the way it happens you're
like oh because you don't you don't
think I you think it that'd be some
really elaborate thing that would you
know to spoil it you think of something
really elaborate that would get L caught
up but it's not and it just it gives
this really great human element to it
it's the whole the whole aspect of that
happening i remember wash that going
this is great I hated seeing him get
killed off but it was just
good really big fight it out you know
it's just you know it's just take it
showed that L was fallible and you know
that cure just managed to get that upper
hand he just managed to you know so ya
know that was all have is so good damn I
gotta go rewatch that oh no yeah it's
amazing i rewatch them recently actually
but a few months ago and yeah it's just
so great so so intense and yeah I think
basically that whole show goes to be a
Greek tragedy basically right because if
you think about it in Greek tragedies
you always have fate or the gods are a
big thing so the gods are merciless
merciless they mess with people people
are powerless in many occasions
sometimes you just have bad luck fate
messes with you and also there's always
the main character always has a tragic
flaw that destroys him in the end and
for light is hubris is god complex right
so very much follows I feel like the you
need to plot line I'm like an Agamemnon
style like Greek tragedy that's a good
point that's why why it's so interesting
like it's a really I think that smells
really good show like optional I mean oh
I needed that I'm on fine i butchered
side I think I'm gonna gonna be watching
now like specifically because couple
episodes were in the middle with L and
the final up to the show oh yeah I think
people don't like the final outfit I
thought it was a good I thought I was
not that happy with like the overall
ending as in like last twenty episodes
but the actual last you episode I
thought they concluded it well no I
would agree that's that something that
unfortunately never gets discussed very
much because it is so so overshadowed by
the all stuff I think it's really
important to mention that because those
were done really well yeah and uh
actually ANBU black ops in the chat
mentioned that he that fooly cooly was
his a gateway annum and I just heard
from goals in that apparently fooly
cooly is getting a sequel is that true
guy is it they're boning it back yes and
is that this year too i'm not sure but i
see 2017 is in general a year of sequels
but i'm calling it yeah she's great a
teen is what they're scheduled for for
right now anyways no official date
though
okay yeah that's crazy because fully
clear was such it was like a short kind
of like ova almost kind of anime right
from what i remember it and it was just
like so creative so interesting so like
artistic that I think it was like I
don't know what I'm watching but I like
watching it was that kind of reaction
right did you guys see it did you like
it that's gonna be tough for to do a
sequel with and that's one to be honest
I don't know how the people feel I
apologize if this offends someone but I
honestly don't want to see a sequel to
it because it was one of those where if
the original was so unique in what it
was and it was so interesting and the
way it just caught fire the way you know
as it did was really was really a
spectacle to behold and the pillows did
a great job with the soundtrack oh yeah
yeah it's just it's added so much to It
Right it's at all like a layered right
yeah I mean literally adds us a whole
new layer to it I think that's thing as
it's just I'm worried that there's so
much height because it was such a unique
product in the way it was created
whereas this is um as someone mentioned
in the comments it's going to be
co-produced by tsunami I don't know how
it's gonna fare as a result i'm hoping
for the best i'm i want to be positive
for it but i'm worried because it's just
one of those where it's it was so
popular you know it still is so popular
but i don't think anything can come
close to touching the original just
because it was so unique i mean it was a
product the time product the environment
and i don't think you can recreate that
magic yeah like one of its charms what
that it was that was so short that it
was such a like a kind of throws you
into this world and it's like so unique
and creative and then it's just kind of
like oh and now it's done so we'll see
they can do like I always try to be an
optimist in general with these sequels
right like I know a lot of people in
their initials responses right away oh
man they're milking it's gonna be bad I
think one thing I wanted to raise in
this live stream is that I feel like a
good sequel like the mushi shi sequel
which came out eight years after the
original because I can do a lot for the
industry he can he can kind of set
precedents and you know a good code
geass sequel for example would be you
know that really does a great job it
makes it even
more interesting would be a big thing
for anime general it would kind of show
that there is potential show that the
quality anime is still around get we
talked about this before but get one on
some of those older fans there were fans
of code geass but now believe the new
anime is [ __ ] that they would be able to
kind of come back and maybe give some
other shows a chance so there's a good
potential there positive potential but
there's also on the drawback is if you
go all the way back the other way on
that if it's a flop then the fans are
going to be disappointed new people are
going to be like who just came in
watching I'm like what is this why did I
even bother so yeah it's it's a big
double edged sword I guess there's
potential and there's for good and for
bad and I guess I just want to be I'm
gonna be an optimist in the sense that I
want to give it a chance but like I'm
definitely worried that he might go the
other way it for me just depends on the
series if I'm like going in optimistic
I'm gonna be optimistic i loved co yes
but like if i didn't love the show and
had like a decent ending i probably
wouldn't be optimistic yeah exactly
because you love it you want to see more
so you want to be like you want to give
it a chance that's what's kind of my
view as well and like I feel like they
can there is a lot of options for them
they could go just don't go the ocular
way but there's a lot of options where
they could go in a positive way anybody
else on does Bryn in terms of this idea
Fred give us your thoughts now you're
not necessarily particular me but like
just the idea of sequels and if they can
be good if they or are they doomed to be
bad and you know what are your thoughts
but when you hear that there's a sequel
to an enemy that you felt was pretty
wrapped up what are your first thoughts
well my first thought is probably like
how are they going to do that like if it
has a conclusive ending it's like what
are you gonna do because you're gonna
have to stray from I'm assuming is like
original content and that's like one of
the who do we always make not always
make fun of but who always says like
original content and always is talking
about that I can't remember but whatever
it strays from like original content oh
it's Roger Smith Roger Smith
or he's the guy that's always like yeah
the patient's gonna show channel and
talk about original content he is under
the weather at the moment so we will oh
you can't come in i'll say it for but
like if it if it strays from like the
original content it's just the studio is
just kind of making its own ending then
it's like okay I can see how you could
do a sequel to it but I prefer things
try to stay as original to and as close
as they can to the source material as
possible so sequels I'm optimistic
usually about sequels because I want to
see more assuming that I've seen the
anime but it all just depends on how
they adapt the material really that's
kind of what it comes down to yeah yes
so I had some interesting mentions here
in the chat we had a reservoir warrior
to say kill a kilt season 2 which is
yeah I feel like killer killed they made
it they wrapped it up but they totally
made it like it could it could come back
and we also had a samurai champloo
season 2 idea and yeah I feel like
samurai champloo kind of the ending was
kind of like anti climactic to me where
you guys have seen it I feel like that
there should have been more meat there
it was kind of just like you know okay
so what now what now and another big one
I don't know if a lot of you have seen
it but a kids on the slope it's it's
yeah it's a slice of life anime that's
like big space in the 60s and 70s I
believe but it's it's such a great anime
that's the musical anime really fun but
then the ending was very kind of a
letdown yeah so we are like yeah I would
like to see something happened with that
um I was like I was loving the show
loving the show and the ending happened
and like it was still a good ending as
in like I figured were trying to be like
very like realism in that way I think
that also had I got similar feeling with
welcome to NH and HK the ending but I
would I wouldn't mind continuations of
kids on the slope because I wasn't a
hundred percent satisfied I'd be doing
with that too yeah I think like they
create such great characters and that
it's like we want to see these
characters reach their full potential
kind of thing right so and that's that's
my actual thing with cowboy bebop that I
know
most of you guys who don't think there
should be a sequel but like I love the
dynamic between the character so much
and I feel like I just feel like cheetah
that we didn't get to see more of that
and like I don't care what kind of crazy
like resurrection nonsense boss twist
they do but I want I would I would I
would suck it up I would be I don't care
if it's unrealistic it's like magic
ghosts but like I would like to see like
head and Faye and shed and Spike come
together again on the ship like a nine
like I just love those guys yeah like if
you have good character than a decent
like overall universe I feel like it
always has potential to be good
regardless of how it ended right yeah
but again it's the writing you need good
writers and I feel like a lot of people
forget that about anime that you really
need to start with good writing because
animation is important and with manga
too right it's a visual art in many ways
but then the writing is really the
linchpin and the soul maka actually
mentioned that he really appreciated my
code geass videos because it gives him
hope that looks this season we could be
good and I first of all that means a lot
to me thanks bro and second of all yeah
like I feel like if like I write myself
and I read a lot so like to me I when I
look at these stories I think about how
to actually make them good but you
really have to put thought until you
can't just you know do like a cliche
kind of run-of-the-mill resurrection
plot or just like this and that you have
to kind of step it up somehow you have
to make it more satisfying if you had a
great show like code geass that ends in
such an epic way you have to somehow
raise the stakes you have to somehow
justified their being more episodes and
same thing for cowboy bebop right for
any great anime like that you know when
you said like oh you need an anime with
a great world and legend it goes on to
writing first time I thought it was sort
on online I was like hmm that was an
anime that I loved the world like I love
the music I love even the characters for
like the first little bit and then the
writing is like broker and it's gone
it's just like what am i watching this
is just not the way I wanted it to go
but the world itself is beautiful like
the animation is nice lots of praises
but just it just goes downhill you know
and sequels like that when I know that
he's going downhill and they're like oh
is this gonna keep on going it does for
me sort online did that even when they
did the gun gale arc like this is cool
this could resurrect it and then they
went back again to the original places
like ah you were doing so well yeah I
couldn't find out story right it's all
about the writing it's all about these
characters and there just wasn't there
yeah we talked about the school of this
sort out online stuff a lot because I
feel the same way like it's a great
setup like I know I like I said virtual
worlds have been done many times but I
felt like this was a really unique setup
it starts off really well like the first
episodes like what they're stuck but
you're stuck here not like that's crazy
that's epic and then you have the cool
characters the first arc is fond and
then they do the whole sister thing why
but then again I also thought that the
gun gale thing was cool to its like the
Deaf gun thing I thought it was a cool
idea I was like okay so they're
switching it up a bit like so it's
another good setup within the world of
the virtual worlds right so but then
yeah it's just like the characters in
the end don't develop enough and the
plot drags and they kind of switches
from one thing to another too much and
they don't they don't achieve the full
potential that they could up so it's
like a one of the most things with sort
of online that really it's really a
disappointment that I think we lost
often mentioned this in RAM cafe but
it's because it's such a true thing
right so yes just sold out online we
make we make the first full episodes
turned it in to turn into like 50 and
take your time and develop the key idea
that'd be awesome yeah that was the
thing with me is like yeah the first
eight episodes two years passes in your
life wait what you know you don't
develop it you need to get the feel for
the world so you know there was talk of
a live-action sort online coming out and
I think they're still developing that
and people are like oh you know this
probably be terrible and I was like well
that actually might be pretty
interesting because you're gonna have
the melodrama yeah it might be cheesy
but there's a potentiality for emotional
stake because you need to build up that
tension you need to become a mercenary
you need to feel like they do trap in
there and just have it compound upon you
so yeah and that's I mean that would be
something that I think would be really
great to see is have someone revisited
take maybe more of a law
run series approach to it I mean they
know they made a moored enough money on
that to where they could probably
finance it easily but ya know it'd be
nice to see so because there's
definitely that material work there I
think they stopped on like like the 75th
floor and they skipped like dozens of
floors in between like if they could
turn that into a long running unless I
take their time with each floor and just
turn that first like I'm cry dark into
like an entire show I think would be a
decent series like I completely
beautiful you're saying they actually
develop it and like focus on the
characters and like you get the actual
emotion involved and yeah guys if anyone
is looking for a writer to help you
develop sword online i'm here i'm
volunteering everybody but wait idea for
a video if sword art online was good and
can we speculate how we could have
actually made it good throughout yo just
uh okay that's go down yeah maybe we do
like one of your cyanide blizzard maybe
to one of your like one of your chats
that you do like a group discussion
because if you guys wanna see cyanide
blizzards channel he vide all the
channels for old anime cyanide blizzard
and brent from burns fandoms are in the
description the links are right there
check them out for sure and yeah what
sign a blizzard does is he has like a
bunch of people make a video together
like bunch with youtube friends where
they like discuss the anime make funny
jokes kind of funny back and forth and
then they also get in to see more
serious analysis and it's really a fun
format i feel like for how could sort
out a line could be good that will be an
interesting kind of format to to do
something like that for so yeah sign up
loser and please I guess I put got this
ball you gotta make that video yes no
choice now no it's just on to think
about just something to think about um
because yeah I know it happen yeah
there's a lot there's a lot of room for
humor there too and then a lot of room
for serious ideas isn't like why do you
guys do this and then if the video gets
popular we can like try to like spam the
creators of sword art online it's like
come on hire us give us a job will save
you will save you from yourself
baby please and by the way uh goes and
is now the master of chat because we
couldn't there yes gozen you were with
us in spirit yeah he's right he's right
there he's got like a coffee there and
he's like waving now he's mastering the
Chad because otherwise we go we would
have that feedback we'd be lost out on
the chat would be just a mess a
wasteland yeah vous parle de quoi we are
talking about sword art online new part
alone this sword art online Bienvenu um
I really like soul maka I think said
before like Audrey no ippo that would be
an awesome sequel I'd be down for that
that would be kids it's just like this
just like a hype hype hype kind of yeah
anime is just like you need it for your
life like actually my long friend bull
Jade that is part of moonbase the place
where we are now he mentioned the other
day because yeah I tend to kind of think
about like Naruto Pokemon those things I
washed when I was younger as oh you know
they're not that deep but that when he
mentioned to me the other day he was
like for pokemon is like think about it
ash starts in Pallet Town you know he
shows up late no one likes him he finds
a Pikachu that hates them and in the end
he ends up becoming one of the more
successful pokémon change of course
again win a league were to save his life
but you know um he does become a
successful trainer so it is kind of like
motivational and the same thing when any
shown an enemy right there is a lot of
kind of motivational with Naruto and his
whole back story right there is a lot of
motivational things there are things
when you're getting into a ma is where
it's like almost self-development kind
of stuff and inspires you it drives you
it motivates you so that is I think a
big aspect of anime that's something I
would like to explore like videos that
are like improve your life with anime
just like anime life lessons or
something just take an animate be like
what does this anime teach us and likes
like I would have liked one anime for
one video per anime and like a teen
videos for gurren lagann
oh that like gurren lagann is probably
one of the most motivational animes I've
ever I know for sure I think you might
hundred episode 100 subscriber video I
talked about how add me motivated my
life or like motivated me oh so we been
denied a little bit back in the day a
horrible quality I'm watching a long
time I am ur talking about like it
working out and the how it affected me
in school and [ __ ] oh yeah yeah no
that's cool that's what I think I think
that's real I think you could write
books about how motivational enemy is
and how it like it appeals to us or an
audience at a mage like you know the
teenage when people are often fragile
right they need something like they
might be insecure with school with
friends things like that antisocial and
they need something to motivate them so
that's what a lot of things like or
lager that's why i dislike things that
come seem to embrace the whole not the
kind of like recluse kind of a thing
like with shinji it's kind of like it's
almost like how through him you feel
sorry for yourself if you're sometimes
like that whereas to me I wanted Annika
motivational be like don't feel sorry
for yourself stand up for yourself do
what has to be done that kind of stuff I
feel like that's really important in
anime or in books or any anything like
people we need that especially in
certain crucial moments in our lives and
certain age and that is why you all
should watch kenichi like that one too
forget it there that was great I thought
the actually that's exactly what can you
she was from you like what you're saying
like at it was like at that point in
time in my life like that was the most
perfect series for me and that is why my
channel has a kenichi emblem because I'd
like my shadows like relates to kenichi
it's like not the greatest but work hard
and we'll do it so is he is that also
kenichi the new one yeah it is I got it
drawn by ricotta he's unreal you have to
check him out yeah yeah I heard good
things the two spooky recommends him too
right yeah awesome yeah
fun any anything anyone else wants to
bring up in terms of this whole sequel
thing like my personal kind of takeaways
that I'm excited and trying to be
optimistic and we'll see if we have a
lot of stuff coming this year we have a
little witch academia and what's it
called ablex which is coming up soon and
then we all of this like winter season
and then we also stopped coming later
attack on Titan onepunch-man kogi us
eventually so yeah it's gonna be spaced
out there's gonna be lots of fun and
excitement coming up so I'm a cautiously
optimistic anything LM one else wants
that I think it's good to I'm glad you
really mention the optimism part because
generally when people think of sequels
it's like oh oh no and I mean my even
exemplify that but it's no it's
important to to have that positive
element to not be negative or two at
least you know look at the other side of
it you don't have to be blindly
optimistic but at least to balance
things out when viewing it so that way
otherwise it just gets compounded with
negativity and everyone just harps on
how terrible it is and it sort of goes
from there it's just ends up snowballing
yeah it works both ways to like
sometimes people hype something up way
too much and then it's just disappoints
it's bound to disappoint and then on the
other hand they're just like they don't
even give it a chance that I co this is
gonna suck they're just milking a kind
of thing right absolutely you balance is
the spice of life it is nice good point
very philosophical that's what we do
here at red cafe we call it rang cafe
but it's really wisdom cafe which is
doing TM see anyone else wanna
concluding statements honestly I'm
probably like mmm sorry brainy go ahead
first actually oh I was i I can't
remember i thought it left so you were
first goodbye out i'll just type in the
chat for a while ciders actually I'm the
worst multitask on the planet so I
wouldn't like will be here any what you
guys are saying why I guess my only last
thoughts are on it or like way too often
do I feel unsatisfied with the fact that
I don't get Blake get second seasons so
Eve
if there are some negative I'm still
optimistic and happy that I will get my
second seasons eventually or like these
shows i really enjoyed like one punt van
mahir acha don't academia I had to enjoy
a little bit more like animated works
relieved yeah I just want to shout out a
blade ninja Otis nerd cornered corner
for coming to rent cafe I know those
guys they're also youtubers they make
cool content definitely check them out
and check out our lovely people here in
the chat and in the better our guests on
the yacht's now that we've had this
awesome discussion this wisdom cafe
let's end off by having you guys say
again what who you are and what you do
and let's start with our boy cyanide
blizzard San I blizzard uhh i do first
impressions of various shows are coming
out during the season will be starting
up again real soon so I'm pretty excited
about that you can follow me there i'm
also on the twitter thing i type stuff
there and occasionally take pictures of
food and/or alcohol beverages so FS you
see see see how funny he is you got to
subscribe him just for that funny
personality love it if i hit the problem
i will Oh Bryn yes I'm Bryn from Prince
phantoms I do anime reviews and
discussions sometimes the occasional
season episodes i still have decided
what I'm going to be doing this season
but we'll figure that out soon enough
but a lot of anime content on my channel
all at Prince fandoms and that's where
all my social media is Prince vandal
well so that's where you can find me and
that's what I do so thank you check out
and finally Briggs from old a anime take
it away and I am Briggs from all the
anime and like I said before I make a
lot of fact videos like interesting
interesting facts that you wouldn't
already know about characters or series
and I'm starting to do some quizzes and
stuff to be a little bit more
interactive with you guys tonight I
should be dropping a video on blue
exorcist which we were talking about a
lot today oh why my fun oh yeah
everything on here I'm gonna copy your
video and drop another response response
everything you need to know about blue
exorcist no I lied about rin okumura
there we go okay
hopefully I can finish the editing oh
yeah cool cool awesome and you're going
to be there for the code geass live
stream on Saturday as well as if I agree
have a hundred percent be there yes by
the way guys so this saturday at twelve
noon easter same time we're going to be
doing a code geass latest news live
stream and then eventually hopefully
make a video everything we know so far
but yes all the news we know so far so
if you want to discuss that come on by
and we're going to be also doing some
discord server stuff so if you want to
join a disparate server and chat with us
on a daily basis we can come up with
ideas for new videos together all my
kind of stuff definitely join us for
that it's gonna be awesome so this
saturday well noon and yeah thanks so
much again through hole are awesome
guests and thank you all the cool people
in the chat we always appreciate it was
our great time i'm just gonna show you a
little bit around here moonbase the new
place we were chillin no one's doing
anything illegal right guys everyone's
super top secret evil men base yeah this
is the boat literally to place the
places moon base that's the name this is
where where the magic happens creativity
the talent hotspot in Niagara Falls
Niagara Region holding it down hold the
developing it down yeah thank you guys
we'll go sign off now but we will see
you next time space cowboys bang